so Peyton Manning has been known to make
some interesting play calls that kind of
sound like movie titles so I'm going to
throw some out you tell me if it's
audible or a movie title Nebraska
Nebraska Nebraska movie this autumn oh
that's a movie that's a movie splash
splash splash en la bubi that is a movie
that sounds like a way to me I don't
care what kind of practice you got to do
this week you go home and you watch
splat 5454 that's actually both trick
question Batman Batman Batman audible
got to be a play call that is a play
call ah who would you cast in the movie
fat man I would probably not be a
terrible candidate for it uh you're just
big boned man just go alert just go
alert it's inaudible that's novel but if
it's a movie what is that movie about
there's ought to save the whole human
race boom room a movie the movie that's
a movie you're doing great I don't know
if you guys can't even play football
next you got so many movies to watch
football is always the first thing you
know we
okay but where's movies on that list
after film after film movies come after
film game film I'll game film okay yeah
I gotcha